Aloha dc fandome i apologize for
the four year wait oh my gosh
since 2017. i'm very proud of the sequel because
it's tackling a lot of issues environmentally
stakes are higher and i'm just excited because
i had a big part in my boy james you know
check it out i'm excited for you to
see it the tides are changing it's
important the tabs are changing like the
comic book the world of aquaman is so big
and so rich it's epic it's huge it's colorful the
world is at stake i'm super excited to be back
making the sequel i have so much invested into it
i love this character i love what it represents
there's nothing that i've ever been a part of
that's like this people are going to be in for
a treat when aquaman 2 comes out they're
going to get a movie that's more mature
yet still routine it's fun to give the audience
something different something new that they
haven't seen before the success of that movie
as the biggest dc movie of all time shows
what james wan and his team were
able to do and in this second film
we have turned the dials up to 11.
it has the action the fun the heart
action superheroes and super villains have
entertained generations of fans across the
that in the globe to play around with this cast
again it's quite a trip we're having a blast
this movie's a lot of fun i think fans are going
to be very happy i think james is really excited
to go all out this is an exciting thing
we better get to a little bit of action
it's gonna be a fun adventure
like it was the first time
just better we see that black manta is still
seeking his vengeance to try and kill aquaman
that's going to be something that's exciting
for the audience something for them to
be swept up into the world of
aquaman again but kicks my ass
it's a globetrotting story we visit so many
different worlds this movie isn't afraid to
embrace its fantasy and go on this magical
journey i think it's gonna be really awesome
Welcome back everyone this will be my aquaman 2
teaser trailer video from dc fandome there's a
whole bunch of easter eggs in here so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos there's
still a bunch of really big trailers that i'm
working on so i'll try to get those out as fast
as possible but just starting at the beginning
of this and working our way through shot by shot
of all the new footage some of this is behind the
scenes and then just talking about being really
hyped up so we'll just focus on the new footage
but the title of the movie is the lost kingdom as
in the lost kingdom of atlantis there are seven
kingdoms of atlantis we only saw six of them
in the first movie so this movie is all about
revealing what happened to that lost kingdom
they mentioned it in the first movie they said
before the lost kingdom had been lost when they
were talking about the great fall when atlanta
sank into the ocean so atlantis is the name of
the city where aquaman is ruler but it's also
the name of the nation of atlantis of a bunch
of different kingdoms that broke apart when it
sank into the ocean it's atlantis itself the city
then zebul where mira and her father are from the
trench the brine the fishermen and the deserters
as the name implies the deserters was that desert
location in the sahara desert where they went to
find the information on where to find the lost
seat so they could get king atlan's trident in his
armor for aquaman so that he could take the throne
but as you guys saw during this footage there was
a brand new scene or an old scene however you want
to think about it of king atlan fighting which
probably has something to do with the lost kingdom
the way they do the logo reveal the trailer
reveal the breaking of the ice implies that
it's located in a polar region like either in
antarctica or somewhere trapped inside a glacier
also earlier this year you may notice when james
won was teasing the movie he was posting pictures
when they were filming they were inside
what looked like an iceberg or a glacier
and the title or the working title of the movie
was necros so what is necros it's also called
the black city it's basically a lost city that's
like atlantis but that only exists on planet earth
for brief periods of time and sort of shifts
between different dimensions and that's why
it's lost not only is it inside a glacier but it's
also shifting between dimensions the flash movie
is sort of invoking the multiverse in the dc eu
in a really big way so i don't know if they're
going to take that route with it in the movie they
might just say that it got lost inside a glacier
and that's why nobody found it most of the concept
art and the teaser focuses on this brand new place
like you see them on top of this iceberg here
getting ready to dive in to go find the entrance
you see them inside this very different looking
city that doesn't look anything like atlantis
this is probably inside the lost city you see what
looks like this whole underground ecosystem which
is probably preserved inside the lost city and all
these new kinds of creatures they encounter there
in most of the footage that they feature here it
seems like ocean master has been let out of his
prison like aquaman goes to get him in the beach
here when he looks like robinson crusoe with his
giant beard like he's pulling a tom hanks castaway
situation with this giant beer like they trapped
him on land because what would a prison be for
an atlantean you trapped them on land instead of
trapping them underwater and he's just been by
himself on this island since the events of the
first movie but then you see him after a haircut
in the same kind of gear that aquaman is wearing
and they're both fighting black manta's people
together so even if there's still a little bit of
beef between them it sounds like they put most of
the past behind them i think that was the idea of
the end of the first aquaman film like look dude
we're brothers so let's put this behind us water
under the bridge to make an aquaman metaphor
whereas in the aquaman post credit scene they
revealed that he had been found by dr steven
shin who's an aquaman villain of sorts in the
comics he's both an ally and a villain to aquaman
saves his life and then basically vows his revenge
so in service of that you probably noticed how
everybody got redesigned costumes everybody got
upgrades even aquaman himself you think that the
armor of king atlan would be enough no we need
a bigger upgrade the whole thing with black
mantas costume is that it just got destroyed
in his fight with aquaman so it makes sense that
he would want to re-tune his weaponry his helmet
his armor just to be a little bit better for the
second round the whole thing with aquaman's brand
new costume i know it looks kind of dark what's
the deal here most people are referring to this
as his stealth armor like something is going
on with the lost city and he needs a cell suit
for whatever mission they're going on the movie is
going to be really big so there'll be a couple sub
missions couple side quests during this too like
you see them running through the desert like they
go back to the kingdom of the deserters to get
more information on the lost kingdom so it's
not like they're just going between atlantis
and the lost kingdom they'll visit some of the
other seven kingdoms as well we only briefly saw
some of them during the events of the first movie
because the working title is necrus necros is
the black city they're implying that it's the
lost kingdom of atlantis in the comics the ruler
of necrus was a person named mongo so i don't
know if they're going to change that for the movie
because in a big movie like this as silly as they
might get with some of the moments is comedic
a name like mongo just feels a little too silly
and in the comics his whole mo was very similar to
ocean masters in the first movie you know forming
an alliance to fight the surface dwellers but
since we did that in the first movie i'm not
expecting them to recycle the plot of the first
movie for the second one there's a whole bunch
of stuff going on in this scene of james wan
talking about the movie like zoom and enhance
around the background of his little office here
most of this is all just concept art of people
from the lost kingdom like soldiers from the lost
kingdom with new technology aquaman's new costume
his old costume from the first film the armor of
king atlan and i know a lot of people saw this
shark here and they're like wait a minute is that
king shark is there going to be a king shark cameo
in the movie from the suicide squad because that
would be amazing i'm not going to hold my breath
on that but that would be one of the few cameos
from the suicide squad movie that seems like it
would be an easy slam dunk for an aquaman film
they haven't completely explained the timeline
of the movie i believe it's supposed to take place
within a couple years of aquaman taking the throne
so he's been king of atlantis for a couple years
now when they learn about what's going on with the
lost kingdom there's some big threat that requires
them to go find it and as a lot of the footage
implies that might have something to do with what
black manta is doing during the movie black manta
co-opting more atlantean technology and possibly
more weaponry from this lost kingdom they haven't
said much about crossovers they don't really need
to have any big justice league crossovers during
the first film they did reference the events
of the justice league film just for continuity
but you didn't really see any huge characters
running around on screen talking to aquaman
just a lot of playback on televisions and a lot
of news clippings and references the real big
dc eu crossovers are mostly happening in the flash
movie because it's a multiverse movie and you have
michael keaton's batman coming from the multiverse
with ben affleck's batman also probably shazam too
but movies like the batman for instance not going
to be a big crossover movie mostly self-contained
in its own little universe that matt reeves
is building i also talked about this during
my black adam video because everybody's kind
of wondering what's happening with superman
and so many of the different dceu actors that
still have movies that are happening want to do
some sort of big crossover with other characters
particularly superman wonder woman right now just
based on the way people are talking the best
chance for him coming back would be inside the
black adam sequels if he's not already in the
first black adam movie but obviously this whole
aquaman 2 teaser is just meant to be an early look
at the film there'll be a much bigger trailer next
year like they've been filming they still have
a lot of work to do in the film that's why they
didn't show full trailers for all the dc movies if
you have any big questions or you spotted any big
easter eggs during this that i didn't talk about
in the video just write them below in the comments
everyone click here for that brand new shazam 2
trailer video and click here for my batman trailer
video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!